87 % des Français perçoivent une
augmentation de l'insécurité ces
dernières années tandis que 73 %
estiment que le gouvernement ne fait pas
assez pour éviter de nouveaux éclats de
violence 2500 bâtiments dégradés plus de
800 blessés dans les rangs des forces de
l'ordre 4 mois après les violentes
émeutes qui ont suivi la mort du jeune
Naël en juin dernier c'est un profond
malaise qui se dégage du dernier
baromètre sécurité des Français tous
quel que soit leur proximité partisane
ou encore leur âge et leur lieu
d'habitation partageent le sentiment
d'une insécurité croissante ce sentiment
fait d'ailleurs la quasi unanimité chez
les plus de 50 ans les sympathisants LR
et les sympathisants eren les Français
sont également persuadés que les
banlieux sont de plus en plus touchés
par les trafics de drogues les
dégradations des biens publics et les
cambriolages sans parler des trafics
d'armes en dépit des quelques 600 saisis
dont 53 fusils d'assaut réalisés depuis
janvier bien que la première ministre
Elizabeth borne ait annoncé ce jeudi des
mesures pour répondre aux violences
urbaines les Français restent
massivement sceptiques vis-à-vis de
l'exécutif Ferrare même les
sympathisants de la majorité
présidentielle se montrent critique pour
environ la moitié d'entre eux en
attendant les particuliers s'organisent
dans certains quartiers le voisinage
assure la sécurité en patrouillant dans
les rues ou en occupant tour à tour les
hall d'immeubles afin d'empêcher
l'installation de points de di les
promesses du Président de la République
de doubler les contingents de policiers
et de gendarmes dans les rues sont quant
à elle particulièrement attendus 68 %
des citoyens estiment la présence des
forces de l'ordre insuffisante dans le
pays ce sentiment d'abandon passe même
la barre des 85 % parmi les habitants
des quartiers
[Musique]
difficiles